[Musique]
mardi 31 mai se tenait la finale du
concours d'éloquence des collèges 2021
2022 au théâtre champ fleuri après
plusieurs mois de préparation les 13
finalistes ont tenté chacun leur tour et
pendant quatre minutes de conquérir le
jury et le public en déclamant un
discours sur le thème de cette troisième
édition la résilience
[Musique]
après une matinée de joutes verbales le
jury a rendu son verdict le 1er prix du
concours avec à la clé une dotation de
500 euros a été attribué à romain louise
payet le jeune orateur nous explique le
sens de son discours et nous livre ses
premières réactions
de l'éducation en fait c'est notre
éducation qui déterminera ce qu'on
deviendra plus tard et en fait moi je
vous connais ducation de bonnes
personnes j'étais je me suis non
si jérôme royer franchement ce concours
maintenant je suis je suis content
certes d'avoir gagné mais je suis
content d'avoir gagné la confiance en
moi voilà c'est grâce à ma prof de
français madame magazine c'est grâce à
elle elle a cru en moi parce que j'avais
un bon niveau en français
le deuxième prix a lui été attribué par
le jury à la jeune du moulias guitton le
concours d'éloquence des collèges un
événement qui permet chaque année aux
jeunes de prendre goût à la prise de
parole en public d'exercer leurs plumes
et leurs voix tout en proposant une
réflexion sur un thème spécifique
j'ai été très très très agréablement
surprise ce sont des enfants deux
enfants de 14 ans ils ont une maturité
une aisance une force
une verve qui
vraiment
joli on a du mal effectivement disait
aux jeunes c'était un pur après les
prestations étaient excellentes il est
essentiel que que qu'une collectivité
comme le département accompagne ce genre
d'initiative puisque parler le langage
sa structure la pensée un enfant qui
sait parler c'est se projeter ses
communiqués donc ce genre d'initiative
elle est à multiplier le concours porté
par l'association jade en partenariat
avec le département de la réunion
s'adresse aux publics scolaires chaque
année et fait de plus en plus d'émules
c'était une riche édition
67 inscrits qui ont été auditionnés au
départ en fait dans les bassins et puis
le 13 finalistes en tout cas les 13
finalistes ils ont été assez
exceptionnelle sur la thématique de la
résilience il avait beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à nous dire et voilà donc c'est
pas un exercice qui est facile parce
qu'en fait il faut aussi savoir émouvoir
savoir comprendre que tout en restant
soi-même mais je pense qu'elles ont
prouvé que l'authenticité la sincérité
c'est les mêmes partout ils sont très
jeunes ils ont 13 14 ans et elles sont
exceptionnelles cette aventure humaine
aura permis aux jeunes de prendre
confiance en eux d'apprendre à défendre
des convictions à voix haute et de
révéler chez chacun d'eux un talent
d'orateur
[Musique]
m